so cedric's worked the count full
and hard right field way back he's got
another one
cedric mullins on fire home run number
nine
and three in two days paul just runs
back kind of inside middle and he just
turns on
yeah brandon hyde one of the writers
said today are you surprised but you
know he's able to hit the home runs he
hit yesterday and what he just did now
and he said no we
know he's got tremendous power now wins
over eight up here the swing of the bat
pretty good 15 games with the tides and
triple a two strike pitch
and there's a base hit
got it down into right field that'll
score a run and the orioles are up two
nothing austin wins first hit of the
season it's a good one well maybe you
know they don't get a good read just you
know slices it
and naylor right there i mean look at
him certainly hope the second baseman
used deodor and that's how close he was
playing to him 2-2 on the way
[Applause]
center field
stewart tags it's shallow and it falls
in
everybody moves up a bag
harold ramirez thought he had a play but
he doesn't get there the orioles have
another run this ball i think this is an
out he just doesn't get a good jump he
goes back by the time he goes back a
step and then comes in it falls
it's still only going to load the bases
up right off the end of the bat 3-1
orioles one in the first two more here
in the second
right back to cuantrell he gets the
force no he doesn't throws it away
one runs in to score here comes wins
he'll score mancini all the way down to
second on what looked like a routine out
and maybe a chance for a double play
well it's not routine the minute he
doesn't catch it cleanly you know you do
these plays all during
pitchers fielding practice you know he
makes a good pitch gets a good result
watch this but then it goes down i don't
think he gets a handle on it and he
throws it straight into the ground yeah
oh two he's done it
base hit right field this will get two
in
santander around first he's going for
two here comes the throw and he's in
with a two rbi double
oh you know a couple of great pitches
and then a hittable one and anthony
doesn't miss it oh hit me
right in the middle
and left-handers where do you want it
down and in just dropped it back keeps
it fair
into the corner
everybody gets to run josh naylor
throw a little bit offline so a couple
rbis and then another
runner in scoring position leorio's up
now seven nothing then now bobby bradley
line drive
how about another double
indians will get on the board as yuchang
comes home to score
bobby bradley is two for two since
getting the call up
with two doubles and now has his first
run batted in
3-1 hammered mullins
dives and makes the great catch
just hit it out that way
they usually got a good result jim yeah
well you get a little bit lucky
sometimes this ball is just a rocket
why not
cedric mullins weekend
much dispatch
anything over santander and galvez take
their leads mount castle ready for the
full count pitch
another broken bat look out bounce to
short only plays at first and he's safe
here comes a run
and santander heads up comes all the way
around and scores and you can see how
bad his ankle is but he didn't keep him
from running tony mancelino third base
coach must have told him come on keep
coming
but yeah that broken back goes all the
way out by rosario
you got to be able to run
to one pitch
hit hard
anybody covering yeah henches gets over
does he get it no
[Applause]
comes all the way around nobody alert
sarah willis is going to come out again
so
you know a little bit late because he
you know his six-six and take a while
and right there he forgets about the
runner
i think albus doesn't forget about home
plate that's this there you go that's
two times a couple more in scoring
position now
and they're gonna come home there's a
base hit at least one of them will yeah
stewart gets the green light he's around
third and he's in
two rbis and heads up bronco he gets to
second not a horrible pitch but you go
out and get it
right off the end of the bat good pitch
yes offline drive up the middle orioles
have 14 hits make it 15. arias into the
right field corner around comes franco
he will score
and it's a track meet
and if you're terry francona you're just
saying okay we're playing horribly now
what do i do to get through this innings
12-1 inside out
the orioles season high for hitch jim is
17. they have 15 and we're only in the
fourth inning we have certainly gotten
an eyeful
of
mullins hawaii got him so exciting
there's a ball to deep left field that's
going to find the bleachers yes sir for
ahmed rosario his fourth home run of the
year a two out two run shot yeah that
one you could tell right off the swing
he had a beautiful swing on that ball no
doubter nelson the fifth pitcher for the
indians today
broken back but it's going to get down
wow another rbi for santander as winds
comes in to score what an afternoon a
broken bat hits and shattered bats and
bloopers
broken dreams
shattered dreams
there you go freddie got one into the
corner that's going to score mancini
well you talked about what breaking the
all-time record that's what eight or
three season record that's 18 14 runs
fight them off find holes
get jammed
loopers bloopers
that one no soft contact there into the
left field corner santander scores
wilkerson gets the stop sign at third
base
and ryan modcastle has his third hit
yeah steve could have scored
it's almost like the mercy room right
right there
base hit for mckenna
one run in here comes the second one
mount castle scores
and it's 17-3 that's just amazing
because again we tell you how good this
bullpen is kyle nelson last five innings
i'm one hit no runs two balls two
strikes
that's hit well right center field way
back
and it's out of here
oh that's
twice a way to go ramon arias fastball
up and out over the plate
bobby bradley trying to go the other way
big fly denny back to the wall it's gone
the home run and what a day for bobby
bradley oh boy
his third hit of the afternoon it's an
opposite field
two-run homer how about that oppo that's
nice he's off to a terrific start man
couple of doubles a home run and a
single
pack off louther grabs it and gets the
out to end the game what a day for the
birds three hours and 10 minutes of
baseball and
just about all of it belonged to the
orioles
18 runs 21 hits everybody got involved